dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife we hear
more and more
about rgbd images these days these are
photographs that are endowed with depth
information
which enable us to do many wondrous
things
for instance this method was used to
endow self-driving cars with depth
information
and worked reasonably well and this
other one
provides depth maps that are so
consistent we can even add
some ar effects to it and today's paper
is going to show
what 3d photography is however first
we need not only color but depth
information in our images to perform
these
you see phones with depth scanners
already exist
and even more are coming as soon as this
year
but even if you have a device that only
gives you 2d color images
don't despair there is plenty of
research on how we can estimate these
depth maps
even if we have very limited information
and with proper depth information we can
now
create these 3d photographs where we get
even more information
out of one still image we can look
behind
objects and see things that we wouldn't
see otherwise
beautiful parallax effects appear as
objects at different distances
move different amounts as we move the
camera around
you see that the foreground changes a
great deal
the buildings in the background less so
and the heels behind them even less so
these photos truly come alive with this
new method
an earlier algorithm the legendary patch
match method
from more than a decade ago could
perform something that we call
image in painting image impainting means
looking at what we see
in these images and trying to fill in
missing information
with data that makes sense the key
difference here
is that this new technique uses a
learning method
and does this image in painting in 3d
and it not only fills in color but depth
information as well
what a crazy amazing idea however
this is not the first method to perform
this so how does it compare
to other research works let's have a
look together
previous methods have a great deal of
warping and distortions on the bathtub
here
and if you look at the new method you
see that it is much cleaner
there is still a tiny bit of warping but
it is significantly better
the dog head here with this previous
method seems to be
bobbing around a great deal while
the other methods also have some
problems with it look at this too
and if you look at how the new method
handles it it is
significantly more stable and you see
that these previous techniques
are from just one or two years ago
it is unbelievable how far we have come
since
bravo so this was a qualitative
comparison
or in other words we looked at the
results
what about the quantitative differences
what do the numbers say
look at the psnr column here this means
the peak signal to noise ratio
this is subject to maximization as the
up arrow denotes here
the higher the better the difference is
between
one half to two and a half points when
compared to previous methods
which does not sound like a lot at all
so
what happened here note that psnr is not
a linear
but a logarithmic scale so this means
that a small numeric difference
typically translates to a great deal of
difference in the images
even if the numeric difference is just
0.5 points
on the ps on r scale however if you look
at ssim
the structural similarity metric all of
them are quite similar and the previous
technique
appears to be even winning here but this
was a method that warped the doghead
and in the visual comparisons the new
method came out
significantly better than this so what
is going on here
well have a look at this metric lpips
which was developed at the uc berkeley
open ai
and adobe research at the risk of
simplifying the situation
this uses a neural network to look at an
image and
uses its inner representation to decide
how close the two images are
to each other loosely speaking it kind
of
thinks about the differences as we
humans do
and is an excellent tool to compare
images and
sure enough this also concludes that the
new method performs
best however this method is still not
perfect
there is some flickering going on behind
these fences
the transparency of the glass here isn't
perfect
but witnessing this huge leap in the
quality of results
in such little time is truly a sight to
behold
what a time to be alive i started this
series to make people feel
how i feel when i read these papers and
i really hope that it goes through with
this paper
absolutely amazing what is even more
amazing is that with a tiny bit of
technical knowledge
you can run the source code in your
browser so make sure to have a look
at the link in the video description let
me know in the comments how it went
what you see here is an instrumentation
of this exact paper we have talked about
which was made
by weights and biases i think organizing
these experiments
really showcases the usability of their
system
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments in your deep
learning projects
their system is designed to save you a
ton of time and money
and it is actively used in projects at
prestigious labs
such as open ai toyota research github
and more and the best part is that if
you have an open source
academic or personal project you can use
their tools
for free it really is as good as it gets
make sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or click the link in the video
description
to start tracking your experiments in 5
minutes
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time